Do You Love Ranch okay Do You Love Ranch
everybody
um hidden Valley's new ice cream could
be your new sweet treat they made a
ranch flavored ice cream
yuck
what
I don't like these types of things like
ice cream should be fruity flavors you
know chocolate stuff like that not
disgusting like ranch ranch goes on
salad and onion rings they're gonna come
up with blue cheese like how about a
thousand island ice cream it's like come
on man branch
Ranch
ice cream who is eating that like how
fat do you have to be well you've just
given up and you're like give me the
ranch ice cream like
are you just like having a hamburger and
then putting a ranch ice cream on top
the hamburger and then that's how you're
gonna eat that I just don't know what
goes with ranch ice cream
I just or do you put lettuce on it